[Music]
on this labor day monday political
parties trying to win over workers
their platform seems to be the most
aggressive the surprising parallels
between pledges the conservatives
accused of connections to a canadian gun
lobby we're going to be building
something here as aaron o'toole faces
questions about trust
prison break the criminals who dug
themselves into deeper trouble
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin tonight with a raucous and
violent attempt to derail the liberal
leader
[Applause]
justin trudeau was in london ontario
when rocks were thrown at him it's not
clear if trudeau was hurt the so-called
protesters were demanding that there be
no more lockdowns and no vaccine
passports they were also shouting
support for the ppc a reference to the
people's party of canada
this is a critical week in the federal
campaign there are now just 14 days
until the vote and the parties are
scrambling to gain an edge in what's
become a very tight race today all three
main party leaders were in ontario
earlier justin trudeau campaigned in the
city of welland as well as london aaron
o'toole was in ottawa and jugmeet singh
in hamilton the focus was labor day and
what they do to help working canadians
here's abigail beeman with a look at
what the parties are promising for
workers
commit commit commit today to improve
improve improve access to the paid sick
leave program
slamming justin trudeau for not
committing to 10 days of paid sick leave
before he hit the campaign trail no
surprise from the pro-worker pro-union
new democrats the liberal strategy has
always been
why deliver it when you can just
campaign on it and the orange platform
has other big promises for laborers like
a 20 federal minimum wage their platform
in so far as it relates to employees
seems to be the most aggressive on this
labor day i'm happy to be here to talk
about standing up for workers but aaron
o'toole's blue team is now targeting the
blue-collar vote
we looked at all three platforms and the
emphasis may surprise you conservatives
mentioned workers the most liberals just
behind
that means the ndp come in last you may
also be surprised by overlap between all
three party promises liberals and ndp
both committing to ten paid sick days
all three propose tax credits for
construction workers or skilled trades
if they have to move
identical down to the dollar for
liberals and conservatives a four
thousand dollar deduction
those parties both promising to expand
the canada workers benefit too for the
most vulnerable both would make the
payments quarterly the liberals say
they'll help one million more people the
conservatives say they'll double the
amount to 2 800
how do you win those worker votes that
conservatives are now trying to target
workers aren't fools until he comes
forward with a costed platform
i'm not going to give his platform any
credence justin trudeau is also not
giving any credence to the dozens of
angry profane shouters who continue to
dog his campaign monday he said
protesters isn't the right term calling
them anti-vaxxer mobs who don't get to
dictate how the country gets through the
pandemic robin abigail beeman in
brantford ontario
conservative leader erin o'toole spent
another day under fire over his position
on gun control his party's platform
originally promised to undo a liberal
ban on certain firearms but yesterday
o'toole said he'd keep the ban if he
were elected and tonight the party
finally admits it's changed its platform
our david aiken is following the
conservative campaign for us david
robin the liberal war room has dug up a
2018 recording featuring fred delorey
now delorey is currently the
conservative national campaign manager
he's running the election campaign for
the tories but in 2018 he was a
registered lobbyist for the national
firearms association the nfa now the nfa
has fiercely opposed liberal attempts to
tighten gun laws and in this recording
which the liberals provided to global
news delorean is making the case that
the nfa needs to politically mobilize
itself to defeat liberal mps we're going
to be building something here a
permanent structure within the nfa to
really
to give ourselves a much louder voice in
the writings as well to make sure that
politicians are hearing us loud and
clear
fast forward two years and delorean's
first managing aaron o'toole's run for
conservative leader and is now running
the national conservative election
campaign but o'toole says delorey did
not formalize any relationship between
the national firearms association and
the conservatives there is zero quid pro
quo delorey through a party spokesman
confirmed what his leaders said and
noted that he had severed his business
relationship with the nfa more than two
years ago before the last election on
top of that when it came time to endorse
a candidate in the conservative
leadership race of 2020 the nfa did not
endorse o'toole it endorsed derek sloan
but o'toole may have trouble with some
in his own caucus on this issue hours
after o'toole said sunday that he would
keep the liberal restrictions in place
an incumbent conservative running in a
southeastern bc writing rob morrison
said on facebook quote the conservative
position has not changed and is as it
always has been we will repeal the
liberal gun ban o'tool on saturday said
morrison is incorrect i'm the leader
and we will have an approach focused on
public safety
focus on maintaining restrictions in
place
and having
a review of our classification system
that removes
the politics from this but o'toole's
flip-flop on guns is now ammunition for
his opponents who say he cannot be
trusted canadians are beginning to know
what those of us who watch him in the
house have known for a long time about
aaron o'toole
is that he'll say anything
to try and get elected
david the first english language debate
is set for thursday what will you be
watching for
and it's the only english language
debate rob and that's why it will be
even more important than normal now for
this debate o'toole goes into it
arguably as the front runner and that's
because he has run a pretty safe
campaign he's managed to move his party
to the center and it's going to be
justin trudeau on the attack trying to
move o'toole back out there to the right
wing and the liberals will do that using
some familiar wedge issues gun control
be one abortion two-tier health care i
expect that o'toole is ready with some
responses to brush aside those attacks
but trudeau was also going to have some
incoming fire one of the most effective
moments from the french language debate
last week was when ndp leader jugmeet
singh
pressed trudeau on the question that
seems to have made a lot of voters angry
which is why are we even having this
election as the pandemic's fourth wave
ramps up robin david aiken in ottawa
thanks david
travel restrictions are easing for fully
vaccinated international travelers
coming to canada starting tomorrow
morning for nationals will be able to
enter canada for non-essential reasons
like tourism without having to
quarantine for 14 days but they must
have a negative kovid 19 test result
taken no more than 72 hours before their
flight travelers must have no symptoms
or signs of covet 19 and they need to
submit their information through the
arrivedcan app or website
this labor day marks the start of a very
uncertain autumn in the u.s the delta
variant is surging and hospitals are
being pushed to the brink that country
is now averaging more than 1500 deaths
per day for the first time since march
and there are more than 161 000 new
cases per day many of them involve
children under 12 who are not eligible
for vaccines as jackson proskow reports
as they head back to school many
companies are scrapping back to work
plans to help curb the spread of covet
19.
for americans the long weekend brought
packed beaches
crowded stadiums and overflowing
hospitals and people are like yeah
it's all open it's all free and it's
devastating to me despite the widespread
availability of vaccines daily coveted
cases and deaths in the u.s have surged
to levels not seen since january some
states are seeing their worst days of
the pandemic in five states less than 10
percent of icu beds are available there
are
no
vaccinated
coveted critically ill patients in these
units among the hospitalized are a
growing number of children most still
too young to be vaccinated in places
where school resumed in august tens of
thousands of students have contracted
the virus and hundreds of schools have
already been forced to shut their doors
it all suggests a tough fall ahead as
more students go back what we're
learning now is that the little kids who
are under the age of 12 not old enough
to be vaccinated are often getting
infected from
unvaccinated adults and really in the
school setting right in my opinion
anyone over the age of 12
who goes into that school has to be
vaccinated at the same time a resurging
pandemic risks reinfecting the american
economy
job creation has slowed travel and
tourism are once again dropping off
while major companies like google and
apple have scrapped return to work plans
pushing them to the spring of 2022 all
of it adds urgency to the push for
booster shots which could begin to roll
out to americans later this month with
fda approval we were hoping that we
would get
the
both the candidates both products
moderna and fisa
rolled out by the week of the 20th too
late to save thousands of lives or quell
the current surge in just a few short
weeks the delta variant has undone a
summer's worth of optimism delivering a
hard dose of reality for fall
jackson proskow global news washington
the taliban is claiming victory in the
panchir valley the final holdout in
afghanistan the region has a long
history of resistance first in the 1980s
against the soviet occupation and later
against the taliban when it controlled
parts of the country up until 2001
resistance fighters deny they've been
defeated but after more than 40 years of
conflict afghans may settle for any
stability even if it comes with taliban
rules here's crystal kumanski
few things are simple or straightforward
in afghanistan take the black and white
taliban flag being raised in the capital
of panchayat province
the taliban released the video a signal
it's over for resistance fighters but
even that is disputed the head of the
national resistance front of afghanistan
has called for an uprising saying
fighters are still present in all
strategic positions here we might have a
situation where both narratives are
correct sayed khan a senior lecturer and
director of global studies at wayne
state university says controlling even
part of panshir shows the taliban's
ability to take elusive battle zones the
fact that they
now have control over the entire country
provides the taliban with a claim of
legitimacy and certainly a claim of a
mandate that they're going to follow
where it's not just a matter of ruling
from kabul
a taliban spokesperson says the
electricity will be restored and food
sent to the holdout region more than 60
percent of the afghan population is
under the age of 25. the country which
has been at war or in conflict for more
than 40 years is one of the world's
poorest
this man in search of work in kabul says
we poor people only want to work the
governments are all the same to us makes
no difference to us
but there is a difference for many women
taliban members reportedly used tear gas
and tasered female demonstrators this
past weekend and female students have
already been segregated from males at
kabul university the taliban says with
the formation of the new government a
procedure will be created so that in
areas where islamic law allows women can
work and take part in activities
the u.s secretary of state landed in
qatar monday partly to facilitate the
departure of more at-risk individuals
reporters traveling with him we're told
four americans were allowed to leave by
land it's hoped the taliban will allow
more western allies to leave as
international flights from kabul airport
could resume this week
crystal gamansen global news london
coming up one toddler one set of twin
babies and all their parents breathing
size of relief
[Music]
in saskatchewan the manhunt has ended
for a man wanted in a deadly altercation
on a first nation two people are dead
and another is in hospital after a
shooting on the james smith first nation
that's about 180 kilometers northeast of
saskatoon 30 thrilled sean mustuse was
taken into custody without incident this
afternoon
there's some tough news tonight for fans
of the hit hbo series the wire michael k
williams who played omar little has died
at the age of 54. the five-time emmy
nominee was also known for his role as
chalky white in boardwalk empire
according to u.s media williams was
found this afternoon at his home in
brooklyn the cause of death has not been
confirmed
a mother in australia was overwhelmed by
emotion after her missing toddler who
has autism was found alive
aj l phallic who was non-verbal had
vanished for three days police located
the three-year-old drinking from a creek
near his family home in a rural area
they say the fact the boy stayed close
to the water likely kept him alive he
suffered only bug bites and a few
scrapes
from shawshank to west bank still ahead
life imitates art in an audacious prison
break
in israel security forces are scrambling
to find six palestinian prisoners who
made an audacious escape from a
high-security prison a move reminiscent
of a famous hollywood movie some of the
fugitives were serving sentences for
being involved in deadly attacks against
israelis as redmond shannon reports the
escape is a huge embarrassment to
israeli security
looking for answers in a hole in the
ground
workers in the high-security gilboa
prison discover the toilet floor escape
hatch used by six prisoners who crawled
to freedom in the early hours of monday
just outside the prison walls directly
beneath a watchtower the other end of
the tunnels
this prison service commander says most
of the escape route was actually in an
underground cavity already part of the
prison structure
the circumstances are remarkably similar
to those depicted in the classic movie
the shawshank redemption the cramped
tunnel painstakingly dug with a small
tool in this case reportedly a rusty
spoon rather than a rock hammer social
media users drew the hollywood parallels
some mocking israeli prime minister
naftali bennett israeli security forces
have launched a massive search for the
six fugitives four of whom were serving
life sentences for their involvement in
attacks that killed israelis
the prison is just five kilometers from
the west bank it's suspected the men may
have crossed the frontier or even the
border with jordan before the alarm was
raised
the brother of one of the men zacharia
zubaidi was released from the same
prison two months ago
i never had a feeling that my brother
was planning an escape he said zubaidi
is a former militant leader with the
al-aqsa martyrs brigades he was awaiting
trial
in gaza some celebrated the escape
perhaps as much for the embarrassment to
israel as for the actions of the
prisoners
this islamic jihad leader pleaded with
the west bank based palestinian
authority not to help in the search
earlier this year palestinian president
mahmoud abbas resumed security
cooperation with israel and he recently
restarted high-level talks with the
israeli government for the first time in
a decade this prison escape presents the
unpopular abbas with a dilemma as he
tries to balance israeli relations with
the approval of voters redmond shannon
global news london
there's a remarkable medical fee to tell
you about in israel a pair of conjoined
twins were able to see each other for
the first time after being surgically
separated a first for israel the
one-year-old girls underwent more than
12 hours of complex surgery the pair was
originally joined at the back of their
heads their operation took months of
preparation and the help of dozens of
international experts the girls are
expected to make a full recovery and
that is global national for this monday
night i'm robin gill tonight your canada
is vernon bc we'd love to see your
corner of the country so please keep
sending your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night
[Music]